I don't think Lincoln could be a very
good candidate for president nowadays he
was very unreligious he never was a
member of a church in his entire life I
don't think you could run for president
nowadays and with that on your resume he
didn't but you know he came to use
religious language during the Civil War
he knew that this was a very religious
country but he explicitly said over and
over again we do not know God's will God
may have his own purposes you know we've
got to do the best we can of course
we've gone much further today
everybody knows God's will today every
politician has a direct pipeline to God
who tells him build a pipeline in Alaska
or a drill offshore you know Lincoln
Lincoln didn't use that kind of rhetoric
so it wasn't religion that was driving
Lincoln I think what was really driving
him was a very deep belief in democracy
and in you might call social opportunity
he himself had been born you know in
very modest circumstances
and he believed that everybody ought to
have this opportunity to rise in the
social spectrum including blacks he
didn't believe in equality in a modern
sense and for most of his life he said
you know I don't think black people
should have the right to vote hold
office marry white people no but on this
one basic right in which he caught the
right to the fruits of your labor the
right to work and benefit from your own
work and to save and to advance he
thought black people were equal to
whites in that respect they should have
the same opportunity and that's why
slavery was wrong
Lincoln talked about slavery as a form
of theft it was stealing somebody's
labor and letting someone else
apropriate it and all the way through
his life he talked it in his in his
great second inaugural address in 1865
when he's inaugurated for his second
term he talks about the 250 years of
unrequited toil ie unpaid labor that's
what slavery was unpaid labor and he
thought that was completely illegitimate
so that's really what's driving him now
of course that doesn't tell you how to
get rid of slavery especially if you
believe in the Union you believe in the
Constitution
you know the abolitionist said let's
just abolish slavery but there was no
legal MEC
for doing that before the Civil War
slavery was an institution for the
states it required cooperation by slave
owners if you're gonna get rid of
slavery that's why people like Lincoln
spoke about paying them for their slaves
you know the abolitionist said pay them
this is illegitimate this is not real
property human beings if you pay them
you're your sort of accepting the
legitimacy of their right of property
but if you're if you're gonna need the
cooperation of slave owners you're gonna
have to give them something to you know
for them to cooperate so you know so
it's one thing Lincoln hated slavery and
yet as a a person fully embedded in the
political system he had to work within
that system to think about ways of
getting rid of slavery
I don't think you can separate political
moral economic ideological military the
emancipation of the slaves as we say in
the academic jargon was over determined
in other words there were so many causes
for it that you can't just single out
one Lincoln always said it was a
military measure in other words the war
was not going well slavery was the
foundation of the southern economy you
attacked the foundation in order to try
to make it impossible for the south to
continue fighting also by the middle of
the Civil War he realized they needed
black soldiers you know one of the
things about the emancipation of the
slaves was to welcome them into the
Union Army and by the end of the war
they were like two hundred thousand
black men had served in the Union Army
and Navy that's that's about 10% of all
those who served so that was a
significant you know portion so that's a
military reason but nonetheless Lincoln
understood that there are moral
considerations political considerations
it was an eight as he said it was an act
of justice as well as an act of military
necessity so therefore you know you can
balance these things out but all these
factors come into play
in the middle of the Civil War when he
decides to move toward emancipation
it's after the war that the country has
to come to terms with the legacy of
slavery what is going to be the status
of these four million people who have
been freed are they going to be members
of society are they gonna be equal or
they can have the right to vote are they
gonna have civil equality economic
equality or are they going to be a
separate cast you know unequal
second-class citizens that was the
fundamental problem of reconstruction
Lincoln didn't live to face that problem
in his second inaugural as I said he
kind of put the problem on the agenda
when he talks about the 250 years of
slavery he's telling the country we got
to come to terms with what the
consequences of this are and an
interesting thing about that speech he
didn't call it southern slavery he
called it American slavery in other
words this was a this was a
responsibility of the entire country it
was he didn't point his finger at the
South and say you are responsible for
slavery he said we are all responsible
we have all benefited from slavery in
one way or another so you know the
Reconstruction period Lincoln did not
live into that period it's a great
tragedy because the president who
succeeded him Andrew Johnson was the
opposite of Lincoln he was stubborn he
was racist he was unwilling and unable
to work with Congress he had no regard
for the rights of black people
whatsoever and I think he stymied a lot
of the positive efforts toward equality
that could have been taken at that point
so you know in the Civil War Lincoln's
interest is winning the war but at the
end of his life he's beginning to think
about the consequences of slavery but
his life is cut short before he really
has an opportunity to you know take any
real action on that regard
you